Given that,
I know that people vary in their cognitive abilities tremendously and that
that's actually an important determinant of their life outcome,
it seems to me.
So let's say someone tests out in an Iq of around 150,
and so you can say,
look,
you know,
you're pretty damn smart.
You're,
you're up above 85% of the general population.
You,
you could,
you could probably do a pretty damn good job as an undergraduate and university
if you were also disciplined,
right?
If you were conscientious,
he hit the books hard,
you're going to,
you're going to come out in the top core tile of your class,
assuming that you're not at a spectacularly success,
uh,
spectacularly selective university,
but you're going to have a much more difficult time as a master's student and
phd level stuff is going to be,
you're going to be pushing your luck too to really master that.
But you know,
you could be,
here's a,
here's a domain of,
of,
uh,
what would you call it,
industrial organizational activity where you could really be in the top 10
percentile.
You know,
it's like,
so if you have an Iq of 115 like you might make one bang up plumber and you
could have a spectacularly successful career as a plumber and maybe as a manager
of other plumbers and all of that.
And you know,
and I mean I actually happened to be a real FSCO now two of the trade.
So I certainly don't think of that as something that's a,
that's a low quality or low status occupation in the least.
But we would,
we would like to tell people,
okay,
here's,
here's a,
here's an intellectual domain that's probably too high for you to be successful
without
working insane hours to,
to,
to close the gap.
Because you can do that with insane work up to some,
some limited degree.
But it seems to me that the logical thing to do,
at least in part is to give people a sense of what their advantages and
limitations are and then say to them,
okay,
well given that here's a place that you could go where you could be optimally
successful.
And so,
you know,
that's Kinda my take from a policy perspective let's say.
But like what have you thought about,
you know,
the massive diversity and intellectual ability mean what are the implications
from a policy perspective as far as you're concerned?
Well,
I think vocational guidance is clearly one.
I actually did some consulting and some research for a nonprofit group called
the Johnson O'connor Foundation,
which is a vocational testing.
They're not that big on g,
but they have their own battery of tests.
They bring someone in and do a full day of cognitive tests.
And from that they give some advice about what kinds of professions match their
cognitive strengths and weaknesses.
And I actually did some brain imaging,
uh,
on their test and was Neil.
Very interesting stuff.
Um,
do you think they do see it?
Cause it's to do the psychometrics properly with regards to vocational guidance
because we don't really know.
We don't have a good handle on how to classify jobs into their various subtypes.
Like John Holland has done some good work doing that.
But,
but there's so many jobs and it's hard to figure out,
well what makes two jobs the same or similar,
you know?
No,
I was at Hopkins when Harlan was there and some of my friends were graduate
students work for him and I learned all about that vocational testing.
It's very powerful.
And as you know it's,
that's more his,
his scales have kind of morphed into more personality like dementia.
Yeah.
What about that's it.
You want it map the,
well that's exactly the nexus that we want to play out.
It's like,
okay,
because there is a reason,
I know people have been mapping Hollins Homans job categories onto the big five
and we have a fair bit of success,
you know,
and we're hoping that the differentiation down to the to 10 levels of
personality will provide even more precision.
But,
but with more general policy let,
okay,
so fine.
So
reasonable vocational counseling,
that's a good idea.
When does it start?
Does it start in junior high?
Like do you do what
the Europeans do and start to track people into trades?
And,
and,
and higher education at that kind of early age.
Europeans seem to have had great success with that.
So it's certainly the Germans in particular.
Yeah.
So it's reasonable to look at.
But the problem in the United States,
there were so many problems with the way we
conceptualize education and the whole idea of tracking,
I don't know how it is in Canada,
but in the United States,
this idea of tracking has a very negative valence to it.
You know,
segregating the smart kids into one,
one a set of classes and the less smart kids in daughters.
And then there's remedial education and,
and there's been a tendency,
a strong tendency in the United States to feel that kids learn from each other.
So you don't want homogeneous groups based on learning ability.
Your want.
Yeah.
So funny.
So because it's so funny because the people say that with regards to two,
let's say academic achievement,
but they play exactly the opposite stomach when it comes to such things as has
childhood sports.
You know?
So if you look at football for example,
it's like,
well,
hey,
let's segregate like ability.
It's like you don't have the people who stumble around on the field dropping the
ball all the time,
play with the top end quarterbacks,
and nobody thinks there's a problem with that.
If they don't say,
well,
everyone learns from everyone else in that situation.
So to me it speaks more of a refusal to admit to the stark reality that there
are massive cognitive differences between people and to try to actually start to
address that with some degree of seriousness.